VISHAY NIHALANI: Thanks
for coming out today.
My name is Vishay Nihalani.
And I'm joined by Flo Thng.
Flo and I are both product
managers who work
at Google on AdMob.
So just by show of hands, how
many of you here are familiar
with AdMob?
And how many of you are
app developers?
Excellent.
And how many of you app
developers have actually
included AdMob in one of your
applications, either to
monetize or use AdMob
to promote?
FLORENCE THNG: Yay!
VISHAY NIHALANI: Well, it's
great to see that so many of
you are active and
have used AdMob.
You guys are at the center of
a thriving mobile ecosystem.
And we're really proud
to be part of that.
Every day we see that users are
downloading more and more
applications and spending
more time in those
applications as well.
So at AdMob, our goal is to help
be a partner for you and
help you promote and monetize
your application successfully.
The pace of growth
is absolutely
staggering with apps.
And no doubt, that growth
creates some interesting
challenges.
At AdMob, we see three
major challenges.
These are around discovery,
monetization, and the user
experience.
There are now over 1.6 million
applications across the Google
Play and iOS app stores
combined.
That's great choice for users.
But what does that mean for
you as an app developer?
As an app developer, that
means that you have to
constantly jockey for place in
the marketplace rankings in
order to get your app in
front of your users.
So it's important to be
incredibly deliberate about
how you promote your
app to your users.
On the monetization side, as
your user base grows, you
expect your revenue
to grow with it.
And doing that might
involve working
with multiple ad networks.
But working with multiple ad
networks can be challenging
both technically and
operationally.
And on the user experience side,
it's important to be
tactful about how you show
ads to your users.
A bad experience can ruin
the user's experience.
It can put off your existing
users from using your app.
And it can turn away new users,
if they see bad reviews
in the app store.
And as a developer, you're
including content from
third-party sources.
So you want to make sure that
the content that shows up in
your application enhances
your brand, rather
than tarnishes it.
You want to make sure that the
ads that show up are relevant,
engaging, and appropriate
for your users.
So at AdMob, we have large
teams that are focused on
solving some of these
challenges for you.
On the discovery front, we're
working with Google Play to
help drive more app downloads.
We just announced that there are
a bit over 48 billion app
downloads through Google Play.
This is tremendous.
On the monetization front, we're
committed to driving
more app spend into
mobile apps.
Just this year, we announced a
partnership with AdWords to
allow the over one million
advertisers in AdWords to
reach your users
in mobile apps.
This is just the first step to
opening the floodgates of
monetization.
And we hope to see tremendous
growth in this area.
And of course, we want to help
preserve the user experience.
We have a team at AdMob that's
working on building innovative
new ad formats that help
preserve the user's experience
within your application.
We're building ad formats that
inherently verify that the
user is actually interested in
the ad content before kicking
them out of your app and
onto the landing page.
So with an eye toward solving
some of these challenges, I'm
really excited to announce the
launch of a brand new AdMob.
This new AdMob is laser-focused
on apps.
At the same time, we've brought
the power of AdSense
and AdWords to mobile apps.
We've leveraged more than a
decade of innovation and
experience to bring you the
scale and reliability that
Google offers across all
of its ads products.
Our goal is to make it
incredibly simple for you to
promote and monetize
your applications.
The idea is to make it very
simple for you to promote and
monetize so that you, as an
lone app developer with an
idea, can go to becoming a
team of app developers,
working on building a
sustainable business--
like Chris, in this video
we're about to show.
We hope that this will be a
familiar aspiration for many
of you in the audience.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BANGING POTS]
-Inspiration can come from some
pretty unlikely places.
But once it hits, there's
a lot of work to do.
Designing an app takes months
of programming, problem
solving, and testing.
But finally, you have something
you're happy with.
And now with AdMob, you can
earn a return on all your
work, by showing relevant
ads in your app.
Then with AdMob's promotion
tools, watch your app take off
in a bigger way than you
imagined, from success at
home, to downloads online.
AdMob connects your app
with millions of
advertisers and users.
So now that you're earning
money, you have more time to
build your business, and
get inspired for
your next great app.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VISHAY NIHALANI: And with that,
I'd like to introduce
Flo, who's going to talk about
some of the features that
we've built into the new AdMob
to improve ad promotion.
FLORENCE THNG: All right.
Thanks, Vishay.
Hi, everyone.
You saw some flashes of the new
interface in the video.
Now let's dive into the demo, so
we can share with you some
of the exciting features in the
new AdMob to help you get
more users and make more
money from your apps.
We redesigned the UI into
three core sections--
Home, Monetize, and Promote.
Home tab is basically
a dashboard.
We pull together all your stats
in one place to help you
get an overview on how your app
business is performing.
On the top here you can see a
summary on how much money I've
made from my apps today, and how
many downloads that AdMob
has driven to all my apps.
When you scroll down, we can see
more granular stats, like
RPM, fill rate, conversion.
It's nice to see that we're
getting more and more
conversion here.
And the best part, my favorite,
is that we've
organized all of this by apps,
so you can quickly review and
figure out the action needed.
For example, Line Up!
Is getting quite a
number of users.
Maybe it's time for us to
start monetizing it or
Flood-It! here, which is
actually earning me quite a
bit of money.
So I could consider actually
promoting it even more, which
brings us to Promote tab.
Promote tab is the hub for
advertising with AdMob.
One of the advantages
of advertising with
AdMob is our scale.
Because we work with app
developers worldwide, like
yourself, we have billions of
users in the AdMob network.
And we've designed it so that
you can create a campaign to
reach all of these users with
just a few simple steps.
So I'm going to create
a new campaign today.
And our first step is to
just pick a campaign
that I want to promote.
I see a lot of you enjoying your
Chrome Pixel, so I will,
in honor of that, promote
a Chrome app.
All you have to do is
just type it in.
And you see that we pull
automatically from the two
major app stores, the most
likely app that I was looking
for, which in this case
is Chrome Beta.
So I'll just select it--
no need to put any package ID.
And you can do image
ad or text ad.
I didn't have time to
create an image ad.
So I'm going to go with
text ad today.
Good thing is AdMob is going to
help me make this text ad
more engaging and informative.
So all I have to do is create
a campaign name, an ad name,
put a bid for CPC.
So I'll put in $0.08.
We pull in the destination URL
directly, save you some steps.
And the best part here is we can
preview what it looks like
in different formats--
in tablets, in phones.
And we've made this a lot
more informative and
engaging for the users.
Because you can see now there
is that Chrome logo, the
review information, the
rating information.
The goal is to make this app
informative, so that users
will click on it and
then download.
The next step is figuring out
who do I want to target with
this promotion.
So because this is I/O specific,
I might want to
target just people
in San Francisco.
And each of these targeting
settings
is very easily editable.
AdMob, also, because we're
connected to Google Play will
know automatically that Chrome
Beta requires Android 4.0 and
up in order to run properly.
The OS setting is
correctly set.
This is only going to get
shown to users who are
eligible to download your app.
Now I just need to set a daily
budget, name this, and I've
just created the Chrome
app promotion.
Now what I want to know is, how
effective is this campaign?
How many users is it going
to generate for me?
And how much are these
users going to be?
The good thing is we've
integrated conversion tracking
into the campaign
creation flow.
So if you're promoting an app,
all you have to do is hit
Confirm and Finish here,
and you're all
done for Android app.
Or if you happen to have
analytics data, and you know
what is the value for conversion
for your app, you
can put in this optional
value here.
I'm going to put $2.
And just with that, AdMob up
will automatically start
tracking the users who have
clicked on your app and then
downloaded it.
For iOS, it is a little
bit more involved.
You will have to include a
short-code snippet in your
app, which you can access from
the App Conversion tab.
If you click on Edit, this
nice little pencil here,
you'll be able to get
the snippet here.
And we've made it easy, because
you can just email it
to yourself, which I'm
going to skip now.
If you're an app developer--
and I'm sure many of you
actually have multiple apps,
not just one--
you can jump start your new app
by cross-promoting it to
your existing user base.
And AdMob allows you to do that
easily with house ads.
So when you create a new
campaign, you can also select
to create a house ad.
For example, if I want to
promote the Chrome app here to
[INAUDIBLE]
users, I'm going to just
do the same thing.
All of this is the
same as before.
The one new step is, we now
display all of the ad units
that you have created
for your app.
So I'm going to select Color
Drips and Flood It!, which
means that this Chrome promotion
is going to show in
these two games.
I save it.
And because this is a house ad,
and we're promoting this
to your own inventory, you don't
need to set a budget.
We can actually do
this for free.
Next is to just allocate
your inventory.
So don't forget to do
this so that your
campaign will start serving.
Once everything is set up,
I've set up a house ad
campaign, regular campaign,
you can monitor the
performances of all of these
campaigns through our
Reporting setting, which is
in this All Apps table.
So I can easily see which one of
my apps is converting well,
how much it is costing me to
convert, and what is the cost
per conversion.
So this is really cool.
Because I've set up conversion
tracking for all of these
apps, I'll be able to know how
much it's costing me to get
somebody to download
a Chrome browser.
The next step is
to optimize it.
So if you click on any one of
these apps, you be able to see
that I've set up multiple
campaigns.
Some of them are doing better
than the others.
And I've set up multiple apps,
and some are converting better
than the others.
So I might want to actually
optimize.
And we allow inline editing.
So I can just go in here and
say, maybe I need to actually
bid higher and get
better users.
Or I can go to Campaign tab and
say, the second campaign
is doing really well.
I want to actually increase
the budget.
This is all, however,
quite manual.
You have to actually go in
there, figure out which one is
doing well, maybe create
your own model.
So today we're really excited
to announce a new feature in
AdMob, which is called
Conversion Optimizers.
Conversion Optimizers will allow
you to set the bid based
on a target cost per
acquisition.
Basically, you just tell AdMob
how much you're willing to pay
for users, and let us do
the heavy lifting.
We are going to look at your
conversion history.
So we look at your campaign,
which one is performing well.
And we look at a bunch
of other signals.
And we have very complex models
in the back-end--
all of these.
So then we can predict when an
impression comes out whether
it's going to be very
valuable for you.
So we're going to bid
higher for it.
And then for the less-valuable
click, we're going to bid
lower for it.
In order to do this, you just
have to click Edit on the
Campaigns, sorry.
OK, so when you click
on the campaign--
we're having some network
problems.
But you should be able to
actually switch bidding from
bidding on CPC to bidding on--
I'm going to show it to you
a different way, sorry.
This is what happens
when we run a
live demo, quite exciting.
So you can see here, you will be
able to switch your bidding
option from focusing on clicks
to focusing on conversion.
You can put in a target cost
per acquisition here.
I'm putting in $1.08.
That's how much I'm willing to
pay to get a user on Chrome,
because my ARPU is really,
really high.
I can put in a lower number and
actually reduce my cost
per acquisition.
Just keep in mind that means the
number of downloads that
I'm going to get is
going to be lower.
If I had put in a larger number,
like $2, I will get a
lot more downloads.
What we recommend is actually
put in a conversion cost close
to what you have right now.
So Conversion Optimizer, it's
important to keep in mind it's
not the same as a guaranteed
cost per install.
Results are going to vary.
However, most people who have
implemented it have seen
really great results.
So our early testers have
seen reduction in
conversion costs by 20%.
We work with GREE, one of the
game developers in Japan.
They implemented Conversion
Optimizers across multiples of
their campaign.
And they were able to reduce
their cost of user
acquisition by 50%.
Basically the same budget, they
get twice as many users.
Who doesn't love that?
So with this, hopefully all of
you now can create your own
app promotion campaign.
We strongly suggest when you
do that, set up conversion
tracking so you'll be able to
know how much it costs to get
your users.
And please try out Conversion
Optimizer, so AdMob can help
you optimize your budget.
With that, I'll hand it back to
Vishay, who is going to go
through Monetization tab,
and help you make more
money with your app.
VISHAY NIHALANI: Thanks, Flo.
So now that you've promoted
your application, you've
gotten tons and tons of
downloads, the next step is to
consider monetizing
those users.
So I'll quickly walk you through
what it's like to set
up monetization in one
of your applications.
So let's say we want
to monetize the
same Chrome Beta app.
So I first select
the application.
As you can see, one of the
changes from the legacy AdMob
to this new interface is that
your inventory is actually
organized by application.
This is great for you because
it adds organization.
But it's also great because
it allows us to run some
interesting quality models to
really optimize your apps,
rather than arbitrary
ad units.
So let's say we want to
set up an ad unit.
It's quite simple.
Let's say you have a banner
on the bottom screen.
You can create this ad unit, see
a nice preview of the ad
unit, save it.
And just like on the promote
side, you can easily email the
instructions on how to
integrate the ad
unit to your developer.
So once you've done that and
released your application,
you'll start to see revenue pour
into your application.
It's fairly simple.
Now the thing to consider is
making sure that you're
showing the right ads
to the right users.
So with our new Publisher
Controls feature, we allow you
to very easily categorize all
the ads that are showing up in
your application and allow or
block them by category.
So as you can see in this
interface, we launched the
ability for you to sort your
ads into hundreds of
categories.
So you can make sure that
only appropriate ads
show to your audience.
We also have the ability to
see how much revenue is
actually coming from each
category of ad, so that you
can make an intelligent decision
on the risks versus
rewards of blocking certain
categories.
Many of you also may have
a concern about showing
competitors' applications'
advertisements in your app.
So with this new feature, we
allow you to actually block
ads by the landing page URL.
So for example, if you're Chrome
and you want to block--
let's use an arbitrary
example.
Let's say you want to block
a particular game.
You can grab the URL from the
iTunes or Google Play store,
drop it in here, and
click Block.
And we'll make sure that that
competitor's apps don't show
up in your application.
So now that you've set up your
publisher controls and your
filters, you may find your
inventory start to grow.
And in that case, you may want
to work with multiple ad
networks to monetize
your inventory.
So we've made it incredibly
simple to add multiple ad
networks to your ad source.
So assuming that you've dropped
the SDKs into your
application already, it's
very straightforward
to add more ad networks.
Because each ad unit
by default is
configured for mediation.
So to do that, simply add
another ad network.
Let's say in this case we want
to add the AdMob eCPM Floor.
Click Save.
And essentially, the way
mediation works is, we'll send
the request to the
highest-paying ad network.
If that network doesn't fill the
ad request, we'll kick it
down to the next highest-paying
ad network and
so on, in order to maximize your
revenue per impression.
So simply set up what you've
been getting paid for each ad
network, and by default
we'll start to
optimize your revenue.
So we hope these features will
be incredibly useful for you
as you monetize and promote
your application.
Just to recap, we launched five
key improvements in this
new interface.
These are smarter app promotion
and Conversion
Optimizer, simplified mediation,
robust add
filtering, intelligent
reporting, and some of you in
the audience may be really
excited to hear that for
developers who are outside of
the United States, we are
launching local currency
payments all over the world.
We hope that this will make it
easier for you guys to get
paid and to start spending
your money.
So with that, I'd like to show
you some of our really
exciting new ad formats, which
we believe are really
innovative and will really catch
your user's attention.
So the first--
I often play this game.
It's called LineUp.
And the basic concept is to
clear all these blocks away.
I can play this game while
I'm waiting in line at
the cafes at Google.
And so, in between levels--
let's say I'm
done with this level--
I start a new game.
I think we're having some
network connectivity issues.
There we go.
And so just like with TrueView
on the web, we've introduced
TrueView on the mobile apps.
So in this particular case, in
between the levels is the
natural time to show an ad.
We can actually present this
video ad to the user.
They can watch the ad, see if
they're interested in it.
If they are, then they can
keep watching the video.
In this case, I've
seen this ad.
It's pretty cool.
It's the Chrome ad from Paris.
It's pretty sweet.
But I've already
seen it before.
So I want to skip it, and
I want to get back to
playing this game.
So to do that, I just click
the Skip Ad button.
And just like that, I'm
back in the game.
So we hope that ad formats like
this one will help to
preserve the user experience,
and also increase the
advertiser ROI, so that they're
only receiving clicks,
and they're only receiving
users who are actually
interested in the content
they have on offer.
So with that, I'd like to show
you all the story of Tony
Fingerroos.
You might have heard of him
from the game, "Hill Climb
Racing." In three months,
working long hours by himself,
he built an app that now has
tens of millions of downloads.
We believe our new platform
will help create many more
success stories just
like this one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I like cars a lot myself.
That's one of my hobbies.
I own this old Toyota Supra,
which we built the engine and
all that stuff into.
I guess it's a little bit in me
that I want to do something
on my own, build things, even
if it's a game or a car.
My name is Tony Fingerroos.
I come from Oulu, We have
a start-up there called
Fingersoft.
It creates mobile
games and apps.
After developing several years
for plasticine game that was
still unpublished, I just wanted
to see some results and
get my work shown to people
around the world.
So I started working on "Hill
Climb Racing" alone.
I spent like three months
working on it,
about 16 hours a day.
The character itself, it's
actually drawn by my fiance.
"Hill Climb Raising" has over
60 million downloads.
That's quite a lot.
And that's really started
generating revenue.
About 40% comes from
advertisements.
And AdMob is our cornerstone.
With AdMob, you have several
different ways to show
advertisements.
So we placed them on the
bottom of the screen.
And during game play, we hide
all the apps so it doesn't
interrupt the user at all.
We have users all around
the world.
So we have the field
advertisements in global scale.
And I think AdMob is doing
a real good job.
I got enough money from AdMob so
I could develop Fingersoft
applications and games
full time.
If I show it like this--
is it?
-Yeah, that's great.
-This is the office
we started, just a
room from my place.
You can see me there.
This is the new office.
There's the workstations.
That's the pool table.
Then of course, the Finnish
style sauna, which we can
relax in and design new
products and ideas--
so have a few beers
and take it easy.
I think it's awesome when you
get to create something, and
you get it finished.
And then you receive
customer feedback.
And if they like it,
it's really nice.
When people like it, and we
liked it, that's great.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VISHAY NIHALANI: So I hope you
guys are all as excited to
access the new AdMob as
I am to share it.
We'll be rolling out this new
interface to new users.
And if you have an existing
account, be on the lookout for
an upgrade notification.
You can upgrade to the new
AdMob without making any
changes to your existing
applications.
So you don't have
to go through an
extensive release process.
And with that, we'll turn it
over to Q&A. Go ahead.
I think there's a mic there.
AUDIENCE: While we're waiting,
just a quick one.
If you're just totally
new to ads--
you've been a developer for a
while, but totally new to the
whole ad world--
what's a good resource just to
start to understand what CPM
and all that stuff means?
VISHAY NIHALANI: We
have extensive
documentation on our website.
I can point you to the
support site offline.
AUDIENCE: My question is more
on the videos-- so the
inner-stitched video ads
between say a click and
something else that's coming
next, as you showed there.
How do you--
is there a way that
that works?
I don't know, maybe this is
more of a double-click
question, but can you run your
own video ads within that?
Is there a way to control
that inventory?
Is that all sourced inventory
from AdWords or what
you guys are doing?
VISHAY NIHALANI: Right, so today
all the inventory is
sourced from AdWords and
the YouTube network.
But we're working on ways
to improve our house ads
functionality to allow you to
serve your own video ads into
applications as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about--
you mentioned that you're
enabling payments in local
currencies in quite a
number of countries.
I'm interested in knowing
what countries are
you covering in Africa?
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question.
We have a huge list.
I don't know it off the top my
head, but I could certainly
point to the resources.
We are launching local currency
payments just all
over the world.
So we'll definitely
let you know if
your country's supported.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I have a
question regarding the
conversion tracking.
Let's say I'm an advertiser,
and I want to
advertise at AdMob.
But I'm also advertising
in other ad networks.
So how well does the new AdMob
work with third parties for
conversion tracking and all
these kind of things?
FLORENCE THNG: So if I get the
question correctly, does the
new AdMob support conversion
tracking with other networks?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so when I want
to set-up AdMob, if I can use
third-party tools for conversion
tracking, so I can
[INAUDIBLE] or if I can AdMob to
also track the conversions
from other networks.
FLORENCE THNG: That's
a great question.
So for now, we only support
tracking, conversion
tracking for AdMob.
And the URL conversion tracking
with third-party URL
we're going to support very
quickly after launch.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have a question
regarding the filters.
Is it possible to use a wild
card stew, a block string of
keywords, or does it have
to be that exact URL?
Because just in case that URL
changes on the other end from
the advertiser.
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question.
For now we don't support just
filtering by keywords.
But the URLs are pretty--
we use regular expressions
to match patterns.
So if you put in a regex,
it should work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, I'm pretty
interested in the video ads.
So if you're just [INAUDIBLE]
the video in like for five
seconds, so that's not counted
as a valid ad, right?
So you don't have to
pay for that, or--?
VISHAY NIHALANI:
That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And another question is the
in-house marketing.
So we should be in the same
AdMob account, right?
So if I want to do the
in-house ads, so
we should be in--
FLORENCE THNG: Yes, house ad
will be in the same account.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but sometimes in
our firm, each person has
his very own account.
So how to solve a problem
like that?
FLORENCE THNG: That's
a good question.
If you stop by the sandbox
later, I'll actually just
address that with you.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
VISHAY NIHALANI: Cool.
Well, thanks, everyone,
for coming out.
FLORENCE THNG: Actually,
I think there's--
VISHAY NIHALANI: Oh,
one more question?
AUDIENCE: Is there possible to
insert animated ad banner?
FLORENCE THNG: Yes, animated
banner will be supported.
AUDIENCE: Which format?
For example, can I insert
a Flash ad?
FLORENCE THNG: I can
get back to you.
I don't think-- it's just a
regular format I don't think
Flash will be--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you have any
recommendations on different
ad formats?
So between banners,
interstitials--
what performs the best for
different types of apps?
VISHAY NIHALANI: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I think there are a couple
things to keep in mind.
Typically, you want to keep the
ad placements in places
where it makes sense
for your users.
So for example, if you're
playing with a game, as you
saw from the video, Tony's
video, you want to keep the ad
in a way that it's not going
to interfere with the
experience.
So, in his example, he's got
it on the menu screens.
For different ads, for different
apps, different
things work.
We typically find that
interstitials have higher
conversion rates and
click-through rates, just
because there's more
of a canvas to
create an engaging ad.
But it really depends
on the application.
So definitely play around
and experiment.
AUDIENCE: OK, hi.
I'm not really [INAUDIBLE]
with AdMob, but I have a
question about offline
application and your AdMob.
We have a connection for the
people who don't have a Wi-Fi
or a connection.
What happens?
Can you explain it
a little bit?
VISHAY NIHALANI: Yeah, so,
that's a great question.
We've heard this feature request
a number of times.
We've nothing to announce
just yet.
But we're certainly thinking
about this use case.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm curious about
whether this system is
compatible with these
regulations that are coming
into effect in July related to
advertising to children under
the age of 13, or whether you
have, in fact, terms of
service that would say you can't
use this system with
children under the age of 13.
It's C-O-P-P-A, COPPA,
regulation.
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question.
I'll have to follow-up with
you offline on that one.
In general, our goal is to--
we always keep the user
experience at the forefront of
what we do.
We want to make sure that we're
compliant with all of
the legal regulations, and just
keeping users in mind as
we develop these ads.
Cool, thanks.
Well, thanks a lot
for coming out.
Definitely come and visit
us at the I/O booth
we have just outside.
And we're happy to answer any
more questions you might have.
Thanks.